okay he's the columnist for savage love
and host of the savage Lovecast podcast
Dan Savage hey Bill how are you I'm
great
and you're in Seattle yeah I'm up in
Seattle in my office of course it
doesn't matter we're all locked away
we're starting to come out again but I
want to ask you about your column
because I'm just very curious what
people are writing right now you must
have a lot of people who have changed
the subject - excuse me - uh you know
what do I do and in this crisis how do i
hook up alone whatever it is well what
what is like the number one query you're
getting most the number one seems to be
permission slips people want to carve
out an exception that applies just for
them to sneak out of the house to leave
the people there or intoning with and go
[ __ ] somebody and sometimes it's go [ __ ]
somebody in addition to the person at
home that they've been sleeping with and
that's just you know too risky I've had
some readers get angry with me because
you know I'm a gay guy and I'm in my 50s
and at the height of the AIDS epidemic
in the 80s I took risks for love and sex
and intimacy and connection but you know
back then if you went out and took a
calculated risk and had anal sex with
somebody you didn't go home that night
and have anal sex with your mother
so you didn't put anybody else that you
were living with at risk it was a risk
that was all yours
and in this case with sex if you're
close enough to someone to have sex with
them unless your penis is six foot six
inches long if you're close enough to
have sex with them they're breathing on
you and you're gonna go home and breathe
on people that you're living with and so
you're not just taking a risk yourself
you're putting everybody else in your
orbit everybody else you're sheltering
with at risk as well and that's not
right or fair do you live with your
mother not anymore but in the mid-80s
when I was a sexually active young gay
man I did then why look at risk but they
were mine alone I weren't I wasn't
putting anybody else at risk who also
wasn't a sex partner I know but if
you're if you're not living with your
mother if she's not in the house and
you'd sin you're within your control not
to go see your mother the theory is that
by traversing the city to get to
somebody that could be a risk you know
as
restrictions are eased a bit it may be
possible to bring more people into your
pod the you know to the to a limited
number of people that you are connected
with you know we're human beings are
social animals also sexual animals and
people will go insane without touching
sane without sex eventually we have to
figure out a way to finesse this but at
this moment right now with the cases
still rising it just is a little too
risky I think to contemplate you know
bringing more people into your pod and
the kind of rationalizations people make
when they're thinking with their dicks
or thinking with their [ __ ] to allow
for what it is they want as opposed to
what is safe not just for them as an
individual but for everybody else in
their orbit so do you ever worry people
will get too used to this and and look
we've always had non-contact sex I mean
I remember phone sex we've started like
in the 80s I've never done it it I would
burst out laughing I just think it's
ridiculous but I think you're gonna see
more people experimenting with online
psych you're definitely seeing that not
only are you seeing it I think the
stigma attached to it is falling away
even before kovat nineteen forty percent
the majority of opposite-sex couples
we're now meeting online first contact
online with 80 percent of same-sex
couples and higher and it's just
accelerating that trend now people are
meeting online and that's a that's a
good thing that people were meeting
online because when you enter an online
dating space or hook-up space you're
saying to everybody else in that space
you can approach me there's not going to
be any misunderstanding if you approach
me at this moment and hit on me and this
is just you know giving more people who
weren't yet already doing that a pushin
you're seeing a lot more not phone sex
Skype sex you're seeing a lot more much
to the consternation of Xoom people
having sex on Zoom despite zooms you
serve this agreement that doesn't allow
people to be sexual on zoom' but people
are doing it anyway because sex is
powerful and people will do it and
people will use whatever tools are at
hand and right now the safest way to
have sex with somebody who isn't a
person that you're living with is to
meet them on the internet have sex with
them there but meeting is not set I
can't believe have to say this to you
did meeting is not sex and you know
doing anything when there
in the same room I don't you call him
whatever you want it's not sex I'm not
advocating that you go out and do
something risky right now this stuff the
point of this I'm just I'm just asking
about the future and I like the gen Z
generation I know they think if they're
just talking to somebody a lot and they
have never met them
they'll call that dating I find that I
get questions all the time at my column
of my podcast from people who say you
know I've been with my boyfriend for 10
months we've never actually met and I
don't think that it's a relationship
until you've actually met and the advice
used to be don't direct message for
someone for too long before that first
meeting so you never know if you're
gonna click in person and really click
chemically and if you you know really
make a huge emotional investment in
somebody online and then you meet them
in it you don't click you're gonna be
devastated or they're gonna be
devastated if you're not into them and
so the advice was always you know get
together for that first coffee after you
know a day or two of swapping messages
don't draw it out for weeks or months
but now we're in a situation where we
have to turn that advice on its head and
I know cyber sex isn't IRL sex it's our
real-life sex it's not skin to skin
contact sex and that is what people need
but in the absent absence of that kind
of it's next best thing it's like cyber
sex
it's exes in the name it's not what you
think of when somebody says sex but I
still think it counts I'm glad to hear
we're still gonna have actual sex we
will have actual sex and until about a
half an hour ago I was going to predict
sort of the Golden Age of glory holes
might return because initial tests
showed that there wasn't a virus and
semen or vaginal secretions so if you
could you know carve a hole in the wall
and get people together and then power
wash that wall with the hole in it in
between uses maybe people could have sex
that way and Gloria Lazar come roaring
back and they wouldn't just be four
creepy closeted priests and truck stops
anymore but a new study just out of
China actually did find virus the corona
virus in the semen of people who had
recovered from corona infection so the
jury is still out on whether or not
swapping fluids even for people who've
recovered from Corona is going to be
safe well okay you're you're you're the
expert but I'm in a fast
on the whole [ __ ] thing so who do
you think this has been tougher on
single people who are alone completely
alone or people who are it married or
living together and now they're cooped
up with someone and and it's the they're
driving each other nuts and it's turned
south what what it what do you think is
worse loneliness or that I guess it's
the individual I actually don't think
it's a competition I think there are
people out there who are alone and very
hurt and upset maybe even people began
dating before this hit and they're now
separated were separated by you know an
ocean or a continent from their partner
and there's no way of knowing when
they're gonna get back together get on
those folks are miserable and there are
a lot of people who are confined with
their spouses and you know in some cases
what we saw in cities in China after
restriction were lifted was not a baby
boom or a lot of people emerging
pregnant we saw was a lot of people
rushing to get divorces and my concern
is you know one of these that makes a
relationship work is time apart built
into that relationship there's studies
that show that you know couples who
vacation separately occasionally have
different social circles are stronger
and they last longer and suddenly that
couple where what helped that
relationship work was that structured
time apart built into the relationship
they're suddenly thrown together in the
same place 24 hours a day and they may
be misinterpreting the stress and
conflict the relationship is a sign that
it doesn't work and they need to get out
of it as opposed to this doesn't work
these circumstance don't work for this
relationship and I'm afraid some people
may end relationships when this is over
that they shouldn't end wait so if I
understand the answer so you're saying
being alone is the worst one no I'm
saying it's not a competition like there
are people who are alone and miserable
there are people who are showing you
right being thrown together with spouses
that maybe they barely liked or thinking
about leaving in the first place or
spouses that they like and and the
relationship is good it's just this
pressure of you know in this you know
alien circumstance where you have to be
with somebody 24 hours a day is putting
a strain on the relationship that may
convince someone they need to get out of
it well what they actually want to do is
just find a way even if you're in the
same place to get away from each other
every once in a while you know that
a tough thing for a lot of people right
now so I thought this is really
interesting I saw in the paper yesterday
45% of husbands say they are doing the
majority of the homeschooling of the
children and 3% of the wives agree that
bears out across multiple studies about
you know the housework and taking care
of children where the husbands
overestimate the amount that they're
doing and maybe the wives underestimated
a bit but yeah men tend to think they're
doing more than they actually are and
having little areas has this been
positive for your relationship yeah you
know I I shouldn't complain but I do so
obviously I can but you know Terry and I
are very fortunate and then we have like
a nice big house and we have a kind of a
skill I think that was always there
which I've always said was a good thing
about a relationship is we've always
been really good at being alone together
that we can be in the same room and he
can be reading a book and I can be
working and we can just leave each other
alone we don't you know there are
couples who feel like if you're not
staring into each other's eyes at every
moment that you're physically in the
same space there's something wrong with
your relationship and Terry and I have
always been very good at ignoring each
other when we needed to well said all
right well I'm glad you're well and I
look forward to seeing you sometime
again seeing you soon I'm glad you're
well and best wishes to everybody on in
the real time family and I hope we come
through this all right thanks Dan I
appreciate it we will
you